now we're coming up here to the 100th
episode of this show pretty soon five
seasons in when you started did you
think was gonna be such a phenomenon as
big as it is man like I could not have
seen it coming I mean it was just
amazing how it started and and you just
blink your eye and here we are a few
season it's pretty incredible you know I
made maybe maybe take wolf saw it you
know but uh I'm just glad to be a part
of it so yeah it's great to be here now
you've been working with him probably
the longest of anybody on these shows
what is it about a tick wolf production
that's so special I think it's just you
know he's he's so creative I mean he uh
you know he can see things and in ways
that so many can you know and I mean
this is all his vision this this one
Chicago yeah so you know he's just he's
been doing it for a long time I've had
the pleasure of working with him I think
on I think was his first crossover with
homicide and law and order mm-hmm so to
be here and and kind of some ways come
full circle again and we're still doing
it it's pretty awesome a number 100
looks to be another crossover right with
with Chicago Fire do we know what's
what's going on there can you give us
any spoilers anything honestly I don't
know it's it's gonna be a surprise to me
I have I don't know anything about it
yet I just I just it is special
you know whenever you hope for a show to
get one season mmm let alone be able to
come close to shooting 100 episodes so I
think it's something really special I
think it's something that we're all
gonna take pride in being a part of now
are you back in your group here in PD
after the end of and after the end of
Justice do you feel like coming back
home again yeah you know it's it's it's
interesting because it's like it's kind
of like you take a new job and you go
down the block you know and you're not
too far away and it just it didn't work
out for whatever reason and you know
it's it's still the same characters so
it made it really seamless for Antonio
to come back and you know it's a deal
but this cast is amazing and as an actor
it's it's a beautiful thing to be able
to work with you know one group of
actors let alone jump between this show
and that show and that show so it's
something that's really unique really
special and
backers it's just great you know it's
sad to see justice go but in some ways
it's it's still kind of around and and
you know coming back and working with
this cast is just a beautiful thing I
imagine there are always challenges to
playing a police officer but especially
now and especially in the setting of
Chicago you know where you get a lot of
news about what's going on here and how
difficult life can be here you know how
close to do you you to the storyline or
how close do the storylines hyouta to
real life and how does that reflect on
you even even personally bringing that
home after work well it is tough I mean
you know this day and age it's tough to
be a police officer especially in
Chicago you know there's there's some I
think what's great about this show is
especially this season it's the fifth
season but it's a new season it's it's a
it's a you know different challenges and
I think what's great about the show is
they can really touch into the what's
going on with them everyday life you
know from the community's point of view
from the news media this point of view
from the police point of view you don't
get to see a lot of that all the time a
lot of times you see the headline and
people make their own decisions and
judgments bye-bye that headline I think
here you get to you know see a
perspective from the victim from the
suspect from the police and it's not
that it's not that cut and dry as as you
know what's good what's bad what's
what's wrong what's right there's so
many gray areas and I think this this
season in particular really touching on
I think we're doing a great job of
showing those different perspectives do
you know if a lot of police officers
watch yourself if you have a lot of fans
are police officers and how they feel
about your portrayal of them yeah it's
it's the best compliment you can get
when you know you're walking on the
street and a cop yell out sometimes me
hey Tony are you doing you know so I
mean they we try our best to represent
them as best as we can you know at the
heart of this show is Chicago and is the
police just like with fire and med you
know it's it's the ones that the people
that were portraying they're the ones
that we're trying to you know do justice
for and you know it's it's the greatest
company can we have a lot of police
officers that that work on our shows
that are
police officers so in the background
you'll see police officers us
interacting with different police
officers so you know that's really
important to us and and to have their
support is is great now you've been
doing the playing the police officer for
a while now but in the alternate
universe if you could play on either med
or fire which one do you think that you
would do why can't I just jump in
between all what I just keep doing that
this will be the same character maybe
I'll put on some scrubs or going on fire
and I'll be a fireman or whatever you'll
be the one expert that can do everything
you know they're they're all great shows
and have the opportunity to go on any
one of them or Dean is great